so don't Dennis me I've got these
zombies over here and this big baby I'm
so sorry mr. quaint hey you guys I'm a
nice fair-weather and Dennis Quaid had a
profanity-laced meltdown on a film set
this sweet Dennis the one qui that we
thought wasn't crazy supposedly had this
meltdown while filming the movie truth
earlier this week Toby but Jimmy Kimmel
might have something to do with this
some are speculating that this is just
one of his hoaxes a hoax
come on Jimmy I need my celebrity
meltdowns to be real if that's not real
what is here's a supercut of some other
celebrities destroying people around
them for the sake of art you answers man
you want to get the answers we'll do it
live do it live I want you off the set
you prick now don't just be sorry think
for one second the deaf are you doing no
god damn it
doing live I can all write it and we'll
do it live and thank sucks you ain't got
the answers you ain't even doing
education oh shut up shut up you shut
the put this tripod here I couldn't
script over here and you guys know how
important my legs are to me
so sorry we'll remove all the equipment
from the studio Joe Guidice me yes ma'am
it caught me sir hey you guys thank you
so much for watching this video and if
you enjoyed watching these celebrities
have major awkward confrontation hit
like let us know in the comment box
which celebrities do you want to see
have a major meltdown Judi Dench that
would be
nice it would be the most charming
meltdown and subscribe to new meander
rockstars new media rockstars new media
rockstars for all of the latest news I'm
gonna use fair with her and I'm gonna go
make sure that that baby is okay oh
right the baby but baby so that's that
baby how'd it happen